las autoridades de las zonas afectadas
por las inundaciones en alemania han
asegurado que la crisis continúa y que
las labores de reconstrucción podrían
durar meses incluso años a la luz de
este panorama tan difícil la pregunta
que muchos están haciendo es cuál podría
ser el impacto de las inundaciones sobre
la carrera para suceder a la cancillera
angela merkel después de todo hay
elecciones federales aquí en alemania
previstas para septiembre por un lado
está a mil años del candidato
conservador el candidato con mayor
probabilidad para sucederla quien es el
líder de una de las regiones más
afectadas por las inundaciones pero
quien ha sido fuertemente criticado
luego de que se le viera riéndose en una
visita al lugar del desastre el progress
otro lado están los verdes que podrían
ganar en popularidad se aprovechan su
tema principal la protección climática
un tema que a la luz de los hechos
recientes ha ganado considerablemente en
importancia aquí en alemania